>> AND THAT WILL DO IT FOR US ON
"STATE OF THE UNION."
AS ALWAYS, I'M JAKE TAPPER.
FAREED ZAKARIA.
"GPS" IS NEXT.
>> AND WE'RE OUT.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANKS, EVERYONE.
>> HEY, GREAT SHOW, MAN.
AND FOR WHAT IT'S WORTH, I THINK
IT WAS THE RIGHT CALL NOT TO LET
KELLYANNE ON TODAY.
>> THANK YOU.
I MEAN, THE WHITE HOUSE OFFERED
HER.
SHE JUST HAD TOO MANY
CREDIBILITY ISSUES.
>> YEAH, I'M GLAD YOU DREW THE
LINE.
>> THANKS.
WELL, HAVE A GOOD NIGHT, MIKE.
>> ALL RIGHT, MAN.
>> BACK AT IT TOMORROW.
>> HAVE A GOOD NIGHT, JAKE.
>> HELLO, JAKE.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
DO YOU WANT A DRINK?
>> JESUS.
KELLYANNE, WHAT THE HELL ARE YOU
DOING HERE?
>> I JUST WANT TO BE A PART OF
THE NEWS, JAKE.
>> THIS IS HOW YOU DO IT?
BY BREAKING INTO MY APARTMENT?
>> WELL, WHAT WAS I SUPPOSED TO
DO?
YOU WEREN'T ANSWERING MY CALLS.
YOU CHANGED YOUR NUMBER.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE IGNORED,
JAKE!
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YOU DON'T GET, KELLYANNE.
YOU MADE UP A MASSACRE.
WE CAN'T HAVE YOU ON.
>> BUT I MISS THE NEWS.
I WANT TO GET A MIC.
I WANT TO FEEL THAT HOT, BLACK,
MIC PRESSED UP AGAINST MY SKIN.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
YOU WERE ON THE NEWS TODAY.
YOU SMELL LIKE GOOD NEWS.
LET ME TASTE THE NEWS ON YOUR
FACE.
>> KELLYANNE, NO!
WE CAN'T HAVE YOU ON TV IF YOU
ARE JUST GOING TO KEEP LYING!
>> OKAY, FINE.
I'LL DO SOMETHING ELSE.
I'LL DO SOMETHING REALLY CRAZY.
WHAT IF I DO A FREE COMMERCIAL
FOR IVANKA'S SHOES, LIVE ON AIR?
[ LAUGHTER ]
WOULD YOU LIKE THAT, BABY.
>> WHAT?
NO.
THAT'S ILLEGAL.
>> OH, WHAT!
[ LAUGHTER ]
JUST A LITTLE ETHICS VIOLATION.
THINK OF THE CLICK BAIT.
CLICK, CLICK, CLICK!
[ LAUGHTER ]
DON'T YOU SEE?
I DON'T DO THIS FOR ME.
I DO IT FOR YOU.
YOU NEED ME.
YOU NEED TO PRESS ME.
>> NO, NO, I DON'T.
>> YES, YOU DO.
YOU NEED TO REACH INSIDE ME, AND
YOU NEED TO PULL OUT THE TRUTH.
>> SAY IT!
>> YEAH!
JAKE.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE TRUTH.
JUST LAY DOWN AT YOUR FEET.
JAKE!
>> ENOUGH!
>> IT'S OVER, KELLYANNE.
YOU'RE SICK.
YOU'RE DOG SICK.
YOU ARE DONE.
>> WE'LL SEE ABOUT THAT.
IF CAN'T BE ON TV, I'LL GO SOME
WHERE ELSE.
>> I'LL CALL HUFF PO LIVE.
>> NO YOU WON'T.
NO ONE WATCHES THAT!
>> HELLO, HUFF POST LIVE.
[ CRYING ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> SORRY.
[ SOBBING ]
PUT ME ON THE NEWS, JAKE!
>> OKAY, OKAY!
YOU CAN GO ON FAREED ZAKARIA.
>> FAREED ZAKARIA!?
I HAVE AN OFFICE IN THE
[ BLEEP ] WHITE HOUSE?
>> DO I LOOK LIKE
KAYLIEGH McENANY TO YOU?
>> NO.
>> UH, OKAY, OKAY!
YOU CAN GO ON HER SHOW!
WHATEVER YOU WANT!
YOU WIN!
>> OKAY, GREAT.
THANKS, JAKE.
>> YOU'RE A MONSTER.
>> ACTUALLY, NO.
I AM JUST KELLYANNE CONWAY AND I
ALWAYS GET MY
KELLYANNE CONWAY --
[ SCREAMING ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> NO!
[ SPLAT ]
KELLYANNE!
OH, MY GOD.
♪♪♪
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> ARE YOU OKAY?
>> ACTUALLY, I AM FINE, BUT I DO
ONLY HAVE THREE LIVES LEFT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SEE YOU ON THE NEWS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]